john's with us in atlanta georgia hey
john welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey i certainly appreciate it um got
kind of a two-part question
uh my father has listened to you for
years and he mentioned your background
and preference for
real estate for investing and i
currently have about an equal split
in both equities and real estate and uh
funding my retirement that way
and i was wondering your thoughts on two
things i guess first
uh think about liquidating assets uh
equities and even possibly my real
estate
to have money to invest and what should
be a foreclosure boom in the next few
years with all this covid stuff
and then second tying to that so many
states have blocked evictions
which frightens me as a landlord would i
be best just getting out of real estate
all together
um okay so um
has georgia blocked evictions not yet
okay tennessee did for uh
and if they have i've just been
fortunate that my tenants have been
paying yeah
i didn't realize it but i had not seen
anything tennessee did for 90 days and i
had one bad tenant that sat on me for
about 40 of those 90 days during that
time i could
i couldn't uh they would not accept
eviction um
the standard lawsuit at the at the
courthouse for that
uh tennessee supreme court put a
moratorium on it until
uh and that was back in the summer back
in the uh the height of the
uh the pandemic panic if you will um
so i don't know it just i think it
depends on the way we make
investment decisions and is what our
beliefs are
and what do you believe is going to
happen you you believe there's going to
be a foreclosure
uh boom i don't i don't see anything
indicating that
um not really arguing with you it's just
a matter of i don't believe that
so i i think there's a um now there may
be
uh some property values in some of these
areas that are completely clamped down
but georgia and tennessee are not two of
those areas
um new york city uh and california
people are leaving by the uh
there's a there's a you know there's a
one-way path of u-hauls
going out of the town right out of the
state of texas every place right yeah
exactly and so uh you know georgia
tennessee texas uh
uh are where they're coming and so
that portends to an increase in demand
not an in not a uh and and therefore a
shortage of supply which would drop
prices up for the opposite of a
foreclosure
boom but that's a that's a uh a
migration of people based on
bad politics in those states um in my
opinion
and so uh uh but i think it's driving
people out of those states it's going to
affect their economy long term
it may affect the real estate prices
long term but i all of my real estate's
in tennessee so i don't have any
uh any great fears based on the current
landscape
uh now i did buy a whole bunch of real
estate in 2008
at 15 to 20 cents on the dollar i mean i
made
so much money it was sickening um right
i did mine in a 2009 time frame that's
about the time all the yeah foreclosures
were hitting the market uh here in
atlanta and
and that was really what i was you know
looking at i think today's election
might have a lot to do with the uh
well i guess i guess it could i guess
you could have the equivalent of what's
happened in those two states
happening out of the white house
depending on who goes in so then i guess
we'd have to judge based on that
but um generally uh i believe in real
estate
or for that matter in mutual funds as a
long-term play uh
and so when things are dark and the
prices go down is when i try to buy
uh particularly real estate so uh
getting ready for that if
you have some evidence that's actually
going to occur wouldn't be a bad thing
but i don't know that i would sell
existing
properties to get ready i would just be
trying to
rate cash together to get ready
and you might even use some of your
equities to buy real estate and then
later on use some of the real estate
income to rebuild your equities
portfolio to get it balanced back
if you want to keep it balanced so
that's the way you can do it but i think
you got to look at what's
happening here so it's up to you but
thank you john we appreciate your call